I'd like to start to get started
everything at MIT runs late but we're
only about five minutes so I think
technically we're right on time so I'd
like to welcome all of you to the annual
McGovern spring symposium and this one
is on computations from synapses to
systems so I have to first say thank you
very very much to Laura McGovern and the
McGovern family for their support of our
Institute and in particular for making
this symposium possible and I'd also
like to extend a very deep thank you to
the headquarters staff at McGovern
they've been incredible in helping me
the most inexperienced faculty member
here at MIT organized this very very
complicated symposium so everything that
goes right today is down to them
everything that goes wrong today is
likely down to me so I'd also like to
say thank you very very much to our
speakers who have travelled a collective
20,000 miles from Canada the West Coast
the East Coast the UK and Europe to be
with here be with us here today and no
less on Mother's Day weekend we really
appreciate you coming to share your work
with us today and we're really looking
forward to hearing all about your take
on computations from synapses to systems
so what I want to do in in just a minute
or two is to pose two challenges to sort
of frame frame what's going to happen
today the first is something of a
definition of terms this idea or this
concept of a computation is a very
nebulous one something that I've learned
in my first year here at MIT is that
computations mean very different things
to different people some of us think
about computations at the level of
single cells say orientation tuning in
the visual cortex many of us think about
computations at a much higher level more
cognitive processes like goal goal
directed decision-making and valuation
and so I'd like for us for the speakers
and for the audience to think about what
counts as a computation where do we draw
the boundaries around different kinds of
computations
what does it mean to have a computation
at this level versus another level and
how do we merge those levels or move
between those levels so I'd really like
to encourage the audience to push our
speakers a little bit on some of these
issues so the other thing I'd like to
think about as we hear all these
exciting talks today is an issue about
goals what does success look like as we
study neural computations Tom Insel
former director of the National
Institutes of mental health and now at
Google just visited us here at MIT not
very long ago I had a chance to meet
with him and after talking with him
about you know what I was doing in my
lab and you know kind of questions I was
asking he asked me you know what the
success look like for you mark in five
or ten years how will you know that
you've answered your problem and I
really wanted to have a great answer for
him and I didn't and was really
disappointed about it he mentioned that
he's asked this question to a lot of
people both in brain science and
artificial intelligence and no one seems
to have a particularly great answer
other than well we'll know it when we
see it that may well be true but it's
not tremendously satisfying so it's
something I'd like us to think about is
as we're doing all this work on neural
circuits and computation and trying to
figure out you know what is it about
computation in the brain that gives rise
to the mind how can we think about sort
of milestones on our way to the thing
that we we'll know when we see and let's
be sure that when it actually shows up
we will know it so with that I would
like to thank you all again so much for
coming and I'll turn it over to Michael
fee our first session chair